doc was that right May when you face
Dennis Martinez its shade is that sound
right to you I think so i got the 20
wins i know against san diego only know
that because on this guy a friend of
mine i met i did a fine in White Plains
last Sunday it gives no Lisa needs of
all my games and DVDs all this stuff
than mom my one my [ __ ] game I know
other guys anyone at win the game but I
never having a lot of battles against my
genius and seem like it's not business
wasn't shapes are you probably right
yeah but this was early I think that
season I just remember sitting behind
home plate and I felt bad for the Expos
I mean you were you were still thought
they had a good TV actually gave a lot
of trouble I mean I was a lot of trouble
but they gave me night 85 not too many
teens give me trouble not that I'm Brian
Atene but they probably the most trouble
the hell out of speed like Ricardo that
year so a lot tougher teams because the
speed who is the guy who gave you more
trouble than anybody else i would say i
will prostate chili Davis um really
problem I've suffice it is normally a
thing like a Tony Gwynn Wade Boggs my
like that without wish I referred sweet
Davis a guy wore me out for me I was a
minute miles plans but not only tired I
Cecily decided to a datum go hi TyTy
displayed him out he was tough and we
talked about that once we retired and
just say it's all about welcome on my
hands it's one of those guys that he hit
and lotsa we have a guy that we call
some management spot start did get
chilly out four times perfect not twice
but I could get them out was it too easy
for you at too young of an age I
wouldn't say too easy um wicked by dan I
just wish I'll probably would enjoy it
more nothing I didn't enjoy it but when
you go out through something like that
you know and at my age you know I was
living a dream a lot of guys are
analyzed know the in half or three other
I split that time and you know it's like
it's a job have to do and I was enjoying
it but I can't enjoy it as much I
probably should have not a quick bike at
it in my yard kids I have a living else
on this pitching out and loading your
stuff and what
top of the tapes of now familiar to
enjoy there's almost like another guy's
pitching opposed to me just to Mike and
watch and it's like I'm blown away by
the things I accomplished my fans they
try to enjoy as much that did my plate I
know you're from Tampa but it felt like
you were a small town kid when you came
up and even being around you then at
that that age we were you ready for New
York do you think if you'd pitch
someplace else yeah you know when you
would it have turned out differently oh
I'm still not ready for New York I looks
right now mother New York young that's a
great question I think the problems I
have all fulfilled I think they probably
cured anyway um obviously the success
that had in New York became like we
expected i remember when David Johnson
told I made the team that's fine chain
of my last slide in 1984 how my mom's
dream was to play for a long time is to
help them talk about any awards at that
time I didn't think that arose hear
anything unfortunately it didn't happen
very quickly to my work in swimming you
know we could hear make it also a team
breaking like this stuff like that but
these two have been very fast I'm not
real quick but I think my problems would
have started it didn't matter if all
they can you see the pitch that I still
had the same problems because a lot of
my problem nicely started instantly at
what age I will say it about the 860 is
often things so I didn't real bad off on
the chicken increase which the great
started creasing every year but I really
got like 46 on my introduction cocaine
started then as well and things got real
fast on this because I knew that the
team you had some partiers you had some
goof balls on that team right I mean
yeah there was some crazy guys it wasn't
as you and Darryl who were having a good
time it that was an entire team it felt
like but then on the other side yeah
Gary Carter and Ray Knight who didn't do
anything that's awesome Aaden whoever
thought that team we had the two has 86
who thought Gary Carter the nicest guy
ever probably a nice guys in a player if
that's possible and once one of my best
friends like side my first wedding a 7
um with our he'll be the first one to
leave us for that age 16 I mean a clean
tech guy that you'll ever find
the path we got Easter white good and
joining us Dan Patrick show are you
surprised you're still alive everything
you went through um I used to take that
one time I did think I was a problem
well what I never thought I make my 50th
birthday I'll be fitted to this year now
I'm not here for a reason I take
advantage every day I mean it stays I
guess all you know now I believe I'm not
if a lot to touch another life is like a
life wasted if i make it sense but um
the decimal dust on here in every day
the miracle because this people draw a
lot less and I've done and passed on
let's go here so I do believe Australian
for reason um but at one time I post a
lot my 55 ish so every day is a blessing
how did we get to this point though doc
you know you have the 30 for 30 people
are worried about your health you're on
the cover the Daily News Darrell's
saying things about you like what
happened here you know what happened
here is arms lindos talk I think stop
that blown way out and textual and the
famous fine I still locked out um device
to my question pound I think the place
is offering you know you slightly too
but I've never thought would go public
like that we have conversations before
we got ears point about this news and I
mean I'm sure if I special things you
regret I said things I regret I get to
that point I really don't know I beg
your choice well maybe he had caught a
question or something i don't know i can
ask him but you know I'll healthy i'm
not using drove that's all I can say and
my goal is to help others and I still go
out or not speak it schools school gamer
startup I have a contrast clear colleges
I'll see the juveniles a lot of kids
there are different things like it seems
that because great for therapy for
myself as well and I just I keep it in
my life and stuff like this will only
strengthen my recovered when's the last
time you used cocaine spell over four
years of all views now there's triggers
that everybody talks about as as an
addict you know those in recovery do you
understand your triggers that if this
happens then that happens then that
leads to this I know most luxurious but
a lot of times get new traders but my my
hardest thing was always
the phone and what we call in recovery
is tell on yourself I just always have a
hard time telling myself because as a
base box at least for myself my dad
probably at a very young age I know how
I was horrible like I entire up in a way
or clean mcrib organ underlies correct
those things all time I talk to my
recovery and another correct all things
about myself always had that so hope and
that was my whole battle over 20 years
to do that I could do that today so you
know I have to be careful to have a
Twitter swart when things are going
great you know they can be dangerous but
these are going bad that could be
dangerous so I try to stay to know every
day tried such my life support group
every day and you know just in my beans
and just try to look see if it really
killed because I know the diseases right
there if I let my guard down for a
second how many troubles you understand
why people are concerned about your
health although I completely understand
no more wine understand because in my
history to understand the kids the
weight loss but it people look back to
2011's and understand this I'm not
making excuses i don't have to defend it
true but if people equate to cook our
moving well that my worse automotive the
boss of my second wife um let's look his
aunt's in six months like in a hotel for
six months with a particular one book of
circulars hotel for six months I was on
Benji love you three days and a one day
of wind use a free basic passed out so
six months I was 265 265-pound well then
I'll race today you know the last six
mark of imbalance to depression and I
lost my mom but even for a lost my mom
what we saw depression say which I
talked about on the yes / it for the
first time um I'm down to 220 so they
say well the weight loss it looks
different now the same yeah it's all
saying you can't judge a book by it's
cover fire was really going with a
person before you judge but I don't
blame anybody I can understand why they
would take that because in my history
there you have one of my close friends
come out and say stuff like that and
abroad who she says is my former
girlfriend fiancée this never works just
homeless mother in the house stay there
and you know make us cry my stuff like
that so I can tell what people say that
but the most important thing I lost but
they care for me i will appreciate that
it means a lot did you need cocaine when
you were pitchy
I never use cocaine while catching a
particle very proverbs I never use drugs
while playing on the field at the music
before I pitch or join a game after game
yes i have i've met back by then use it
before anything like that never say
never did anything to sell or destroy my
performance on the field even though
after all the use i did you know the
offseason we'll have you over the years
definitely did help my performances put
on I believe anything loves class no sir
when you see someone these young
athletes like Johnny Manziel what would
you say to him yeah I assume you're
familiar with Johnny Manziel the former
Heisman winner though the big fantasy of
less than a college diploma vs Miami
football fan but um you want to get like
that I'm gonna memo sports and I love
sports what's all sports all the time
especially baseball or football um you
can see the Bible do some like that
especially publicly but um I need to say
it I've been there where you could tell
a person all the right things everything
needs to hear and the personal email in
a period but so that person is ready to
get clean us over is really wasted time
and something you do decide to face well
just give me the facts that person has
to be ready I mean you know like at
times where I'm this manna from baseball
way to go to rehab literacies where I
went because I was forced to go off
suspended all I saw was myself with the
last moment to attend attend recovery
with dr. Drew and I saw some other guy
right okay I was ready to commit until
person really ready to commit really
doesn't matter what is gonna be a writer
law enforcement you got your world
series ring still you got memorabilia oh
oh yes I similarly those rings of prices
some butt off a lot of stuff for those
things my Warsaw Lapid those prices I
might even put in the Wilfs I kids
watching gosh yes it comes to me you're
taking your rights to the grave okkk
another kidding I just let herself so
much way I just called myself back my
mom my mom before she passed she had a
safer stuff and it came up were bomb you
know the first time I went to rehab was
in ninth 87 I see what's the alumni's
who technologies mean and she'll afraid
that also important associate drugs
needle Esther she didn't know after
money her town
work but you know bustle her room she
found the bedroom in the house which
keeps all my stuff and if you get your
risk of the league's of high school
stuff out Lily trophies no se young
awards hockey awards grocery stores
always thought in his room so it's
getting key to a Roman so it's not my
friends tomorrow if I went to see the
rooms she'll stand in the door so so
hopefully she likes to obey Him mouth
sports nicer passed away in July so now
I'm going to get out of my stuff and
displayed on my walls my little kisses
well do you want to work in baseball
like what are you doing aside from
showing up at card shows book signings
or anything like that well I hope my
wisely right now i am i messing up to
the memory array games and chavez and
since he's 23 years old I'm clearly
college we had some injuries at seven
back so it isn't starting I have
millennial sons that plays football
basketball baseball I just as much time
I came with him now because
unfortunately all the kids i have seven
kids altogether i was married twice
knowledge is is about Isis my addiction
or i was awake Lane boss i miss Valley
High School Activities I'm as long as
loading stuff so really wouldn't arouse
myself were like the game so I don't
want make the same mistake go back to
low have a let me no sign of transport
and the sexual double there is no just
getting too technical side fabulous them
i do do other things I've to some
charity thing we just start made a
couple former judges well despite giving
kids a second chance I get in trouble
the cell just like in these close-up
find out the pipe valves having to build
is right we can go get educated the
paintings adherence for the parents
would be angry been incarcerated well
have you decided give us a sense of life
in we're not just constantly locking
onto going to kill wake and just trying
to rebuild everybody there right so
second chance I think by getting
involved with things like this helps my
recovery as well so those are things I'm
doing now foreskin back into baseball
maybe one day what's our first retired
there's a little bit we're going to mr.
Stein go down as Catholics in six years
as fines on that I learned lots of doors
but my true passion is work with kids
well I wish you the best and maybe one
time we'll have you come in our new york
studio we just talked baseball
that'd be fun I know I know you've
talked a lot about this certainly with
you and Darryl drugs and rehab and
everything but hopefully we get to a
point where we just talk baseball one
day sounds good i'll look for that they
saw me there all right that's Dwight
Gooden the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience